so right now while Vox is complaining
that drug companies are not taking into
account the biological differences
between men and women they are
proactively pushing the agenda that
there are no biological differences
between men and women
question of the day do you really
believe that we're still living with the
the remnants I guess of patriarchy and
that all consumer goods and and medicine
have been created for men by men by
default especially when you consider
that women drive the majority of
consumer purchasing this is the argument
that now is being pushed forward from
Vox along with this sort of inter gender
spectrum I don't fully understand it but
yeah this video forward absent we're not
going to talk about their beautiful and
brave contributors beautiful right they
were not a video I think this morning on
how everything is made exclusively for
men and the deck is stacked against
women particularly when it comes to in
this by the way it took me a lot of
research because everything let me zip
this up everything they say is wrong and
I want you to fact-check me on this so
everything is made exclusively for men
particularly drugs roll clip this is
reference man he's a white thirty year
old male who weighs about a sensational
Justice Gerald C and he knows how we
live for decades inches about considered
this the standard human and designed the
world around him everything from air
conditioning in offices to cars even
military equipment but there are other
ways we use reference men that aren't so
obvious like in medicine where it
doesn't just lead to discomfort here the
disparity can be incredibly dangerous
for women
I love how in trying to shut down the
patriarchy they create effectively what
amounts to an infomercial was completely
incompetent women work she's put on the
military helmet like she's marvin the
martian none of these things are true
quick backcheck military only designing
gear for men no it's no longer the case
and her pitot requirements are lower
because women couldn't do pull-ups oh
good for you
not sure
the countries you liberate but are you
air conditioning and talk about air
conditioning in the offices oh my talk
about scraping the bottom of the
bitching barrel not expel the pitch
embarrassin what else do we have to
complain about fix [ __ ] wrong with the
thermostat it's 2 degrees too low
clearly an example of patriarchy and you
won't have to get the world new world
back the Native Americans that would
have had you scalp
yeah I always set my AC to patriarchy
it's a nice setting I lock it you have
to go through in the smart settings say
Alexa set it to patriarchy she says how
dare you I say I dare and she says okay
all right then they start going on to
drugs being created exclusively keep in
mind none of this is true but I want you
to watch it for yourself a few years ago
something strange was happening headline
after headline recounted a similar story
dozens of women were crashing their cars
under the influence of sleeping pills in
many of these cases they had taken a
dose of zolpidem the night before it's
what you probably know is the common
sleep aid ambien after the crashes the
Food and Drug Administration issued a
safety warning in 2013 and changed the
recommended dosage for women cutting it
in half the reason the right dosage for
women had been overlooked is that the
clinical trials on ambien focused on
male test subjects ok first off the
medical premise that they try to run
with in this this installment episode by
the way there are YouTube original is
now being co-produced with us so oh boy
not true not accurate but we'll come
back to that the fact that they use
ambien that that's the red herring it's
it's unbelievable to me that they chose
it because obviously they would have
picked the best example to put their
foot fault if you're going to go through
millions of dollars in production
budgets and all the cool transitions
little graphics that are entirely
unnecessary the xylophone picked the
strongest example let's go through they
list a bunch of examples there as far as
how it relates to ambien yeah and women
and that women were not processing
ambien properly properly because the
dosing protocols didn't account for them
and they use a bunch of stores we'll
take some screens they're still so
here's one right there that first story
ok the Vox lady it's Kerry Kennedy by
the way daughter of Robert Kennedy ok
right now here's something that we need
to be clear about she didn't claim that
she was still groggy from taking ambien
the day before but she accidentally took
ambien instead of her thyroid meds the
next morning
before going to the gym so not exactly
indicative Big Pharma trying to screw
those with ovaries now second-story okay
I think a college student who took I
think they list it there so I had to go
through these stores at first I was just
planning on debunking this is Terra
general idea that the medical
establishment is against women and we'll
get to that in a second but it is found
more you folks you're a Marvel did you
pick these sores let's rattle on through
the secondary college student who they
claimed its totals woman Prescott no yes
he didn't take one but she took quote
two or three ambien at midnight and then
decided to go get a drink at 2:00 a.m.
at which point she was pulled on can't
even remember how many she took the
other two stories one was a woman who
drove off the road at 2:00 a.m. after
taking ambien again not the next morning
2:00 a.m. branches whim if you're taking
a sleeping pill one would think that
2:00 a.m. you should be sleeping not
driving and then the other one didn't
exactly crash as the headline suggests
or the one that they run she fell asleep
in a McDonald's drive-thru again at
midnight drove up on the curb ambien at
midnight and I'm not sure that we can
blame the FDA for this by the way the
dosage when people take a handful of
ambien like it's an M&Ms commercial
before going for an evening Drive not
even a straw mind behind a four wheeler
yeah the problem is she went to
McDonald's at midnight that's that's
more concerning to me I don't know it's
concerning at all and I resent the
statement is Taco Bell's the only worse
option a lot of people since then have
blamed traffic accidents on uh nambian
yeah and they weren't all women so
here's another high-profile case by the
way another Kennedy from representative
Patrick Kennedy son of Ted Kennedy's a
lot of bad luck you know what yeah
Simpson by the way people they often use
this excuse well I took an ambien to try
and defend litany of action and it's
become sort of this legal quandary your
honor serial murder he took ambien by
the way she said dozens of women there's
like millions of people taking ambien
residents compared two million oral to
the story here is friends don't let
friends drive with Kennedy's ambien or
not dangerous
Kennedy's rising you add a
benzodiazepine to the mix and you've got
some problem exactly consider yourself
lucky if you made it out you know above
water oh now here's the thing it is true
that the dosage was too high across the
board so I want to be clear about this
here studies were conducted afterwards
that sort of study the link between
ambien and traffic accidents and they
found that the morning after taking the
originally recommended dose 33 percent
of women had dangerous blood levels of
the drug that sounds bad 25 percent of
men did come on ended up recommending
lower dosages for both men and women
with doctors being encouraged to
prescribe a half dose regardless of sex
or gender beautiful break so I want to
be really clear about these are the
examples that they chose it's crazy
does the isolated case of ambien
assuming that they were being honest
does that really prove anything about
the sort of wider world of drug
development by the way hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot you'll be notified new videos every
single day at 8 p.m. Eastern and of
course of course join one club a lot of
credit calm / mutt club because we are
not funded by big drug companies who
exclude women from their clinical trial
parameters so let's go to the next clip
from Vox there are several factors that
can affect how a person metabolize his
drugs from size to body fat to hormonal
fluctuations and these factors can vary
drastically based on sex
but many clinical trials don't account
for this they often don't include enough
women as test subjects and even when
they do data from women is often mixed
in with data for men which can hide sex
specific reactions to medicine by the
way after that all those little clay
balls turn into one giant ball and he
says I'm going to be a dentist so this
is something to talk about so this is
where they really want to be clear about
sex so for a second do you mean to tell
me that men and women are biologically
different what what about we're clear
from YouTube you are not allowed to
refer to even the dsm-5 or the idea of
gender identity discs don't finish the
word so what about okay what about
gender what about the dysphoria pne's is
that okay go either what about the
dysphoria pne's what
happens there if someone identifies as a
female but is biologically male hallelu
Randle that will come back to that in a
second here the problem is that Vox
assumes these results only go one way
right that it's always good for men it's
always bad for women that's not true
some drugs are more effective for women
yeah some drugs are more effective in
men this is something that's important
for people to understand because it's
very easy to cherry-pick for the same
reason it's easy to say or make it seem
as though the United States is
responsible for all the evil in the
world but if you don't account for the
fact that slavery still goes on
elsewhere that it's not the United
States right exactly you can just take
into a cup some drugs aren't processed
very well by women but the same goes
from it by the way same goes across
races
yeah you've heard of Asian rosacea
that's the actual thing yeah it's a
genetic profile where they don't process
alcohol the same what is this considered
racist because I am excluding someone of
a specific half Asian will tell you
washed I just assume like that he was
jolly turns out it's a problem it really
is a price should be keeping an eye on
him yes let's go to the next clip in
1993 the National Institutes of Health
created regulations saying women must be
included in human studies and have their
data analyzed separately but the problem
is it's the FDA Food and Drug
Administration that's making the
decisions about what medications are
being sold to you and to your loved ones
and they are not required to include
women people of color people over 65 you
know if you're a because you've never
touched that man you don't have to study
as many people the more people you study
the more it costs to do the research but
the more meaningful the information is
so that we can all make informed
decisions about what's good for us yes
because you need to understand that evil
Big Pharma it's all a part of their ploy
to eliminate precise than 50% of the
marketplace yes when studying their
drugs there is no financial incentive to
find out how drugs interact with women
because yes but it's also people of
color Stevens yeah that eliminates even
more eliminate 64% because I'm pretty
sure that everyone
FDA is a white supremacist right who
wants the Kennedys to be rolling up on
curbs at McDonald's in the middle of
night on ambien because we all had a
double secret patriarchy meeting behind
their backs we did fearsome it's
mind-numbing to me to and I didn't plan
on going through all this history today
vaak but Vox left it out yeah you had to
do it they mentioned it before 1993 man
women were not included in these studies
how dare that that's true yes that's
true
could the why box do you not tell people
that before the 1970s women were
included oh and was relevant it see that
it would be relevant as just like the
fact that you know 25% of men versus 33%
of women you yes too many people are
taking too much of the drug we want to
save lives not just women's lives but
men's lives too yeah we don't want more
Kennedys in the bottom of war V newer
Kennedys I'm not necessarily sure I
think ravine here and if there's it's
between oh yeah let's just go with the
river that way I don't have to be
fact-checked so before the 1970s women
were include they were eliminated why
because there was this does these
disastrous this drug was Philadelphia to
my mother my yeah I've only read it
because I've never take my wife could
pronounce it right but there was a
scandal in the 1960s and the drug caused
terrible birth defects right yes
especially it was given a pregnant women
so after 1977 the FDA issued a guideline
that women of childbearing age should
not be included in the studies it seems
protective seems as though will the
double-secret patriarchy immune this is
how they hook you in this is they hook
you in by protecting you Doublemint and
then they give you too much lunesta it's
like we're gonna make sure that you have
children and then you're gonna be seeing
butterflies all over the place it was a
very creepy commercial I said I choked
and have a bad acid trip exactly so then
in 1993 there were guidelines at Vox
they mentioned it was merely a reversal
of the 1977 ban and then they were
written into law studies have shown by
the way that since then women members of
all races have been included in studies
yes comes from women's health this
overlay again so it's not just from the
devil secret patriarchy meaning
scientists have conducted since then
very specific reviews to see if the 1977
ban had any of
and women participating in these studies
they found zero evidence but their
participation was any lower Wow
so here's something else by the way a
lot of studies don't separate results
for the sexes and trying to do research
for this this is a problem a lot of say
they don't actually tell you who was
included in this study so often to
include many different men women people
different races right final results
aren't necessarily divided up among
those groups okay so now that they
started out with this hypothetical
hundred and fifty five pound thirty year
old white male mannequin is vodka Jess
which by the way mouth oh if that male
weighs under fifty five pounds with no
arms or legs very dense not very dense
like that like apparently furniture
weighed like 200 pounds Oh how do you
move that it's unsettling dwell on it
the opposite of the Ramat Vox tries to
present you and this is important
because it's a divide-and-conquer where
they want you oh hold on a second men
are getting something that women are not
getting here see we need to right this
wrong when there is no wrong - right
yeah and there are plenty of other
actual wrongs in the world that we can
right this is not amongst them so it's
the opposite of the problem they
presented they've lumped a lot of these
studies lump both sexes together just to
create an average and think about that
for a second it's an average it's a
genderless non-binary hypothetical
person yeah right that should be you
know something that we can all be on
board goal why do you think that is
here's something else too it could also
be the reason they don't want to
separate that is because media academics
the entertainment issue they've all been
telling us that there are no biological
differences between men and women
they've been telling us that there
aren't any significant differences
between male and female brains and it's
a myth that men are stronger than women
we even have the American Psychological
Association claiming that there's no big
difference between men and women here
you go here's a collage for you
sweetheart remember when James de Moura
google/youtube he got in trouble for
circulating an internal memo saying that
hey there are biological differences
between men and women that may affect
their choices that poor scarecrow mind
when you suggest that there are any
biological differences between the sexes
let's go to another point here let's not
forget that there are some drugs that
are researched specifically yes for
members of specific sexes for example
there you have a libido drug there's a
reason
drug to treat low female libido was
studied on females only seems like that
would be appropriate male pattern
baldness drugs focuses on primarily men
sex it doesn't mean that women I mean
there are drugs exclusively and there
they try to talk about it being ages
there are drugs for old people there are
drugs for genetic diseases that exist
only for example black people sickle
cell their diseases the eggs exist
exclusively in Jewish bloodlines the
same thing with French Canadian and
Acadian bloodlines
I've netic testing that there are like
12 diseases of the French Canadian that
only I can have this is what's really
concerning to me because the media the
entertainment history they've been
trying to say there are no difference
between men and women for a long time
right but now you have Psychiatric
Association's trying to come out and you
know appease that politically correct
God saying well there really is no
significant primary difference see if
people are coming out talking about
athletics because yeah women's track
records are being set by who male to
female transgender dysphoria --nz I want
to use the right terminology same thing
with powerlifting same thing with
Olympic lifting same thing with combat
sports yes when you get to a point where
you say that it used to be men and women
wanted some men wanted to take dumps in
the bathroom where women went they
identified as women we said well okay
and we were saying this could be a
slippery slope and people said why would
use that argument it's a logical fallacy
I think if nothing else this last decade
is proven to us that slippery slope is
not a logical fallacy yes now we have
men doing this in prizefighting with
women yeah exactly
I don't know how much further there is
to slip down a slope but when you think
about this and you're talking about
medical testing what do you do what do
you do when a woman identifies as a man
trans female to male says right I and it
says on their identification I am a male
and you're doing some kind of I don't
know viagra clinical trial
what are you doing suck it up it for
birth control for women because we've
even read it huffington post we've seen
it but men can get periods too and I'm
not exactly sure which way it even goes
if they mean people I'm not no one's
clear on the rule book yeah the only
thing that we're clear on is that the
rule book has to be thrown out if
somebody is offended so this is now
seeping into science it's seeping into
the medical community where you are
going to have studies or at least you
should have studies that absolutely
should study exclusively biological
women because the medicine is only
relevant to biological illness
keep this in like you think this is
absurd
I went to Planned Parenthood I said I
might be free they gave me Plan B
pregnancy tests like a man and we stole
the yarn for a pregnant woman asking me
did you steal this urine from a pregnant
woman
they said congratulations yes sir this
is biologically impossible if you want
to take care of it was an abortion it
planned parent they couldn't tell me
that the Fabri is the elevated levels of
those hormones indicate testicular
cancer in a man because they're not
allowed to dead named you so right now
I'll Vox is complaining that drug
companies are not taking into account
the biological differences between men
and women they are proactively pushing
the agenda that there are no biological
differences between men and women who do
you think that's gonna help do you think
that women are going to have more
success with the drugs that are coming
out of these trials or less especially
when you understand that many of these
participants are cloaked right now it's
hard to find out who's participating
yeah if you read about 50% men and 50%
women in a study and you find out that
50% of those women were actually
biological men who still have penises
but they wanted to use the NuvaRing but
this is what this is the problem with
the divide and conquer modern
progressive left where there is no
through luck there is no there's no
trail of breadcrumbs back where you can
say all right listen we understand
people want to identify a certain way
but biologically there clearly are
differences and we have to respect that
particularly in the realm of science and
medicine no they can't say that didn't
then not want to complain about the fact
that some drug companies miss testing
for Biological difference I want to know
what you think if you think this is a
byproduct of patriarchy or if you just
think it's another crappy video in a
long line of crappy videos from V o X
hey there if you liked this video click
one of these other videos playing in a
box up there and hit subscribe or the
notification bell if you're already
subscribed so you can find out about our
new non controversial videos which don't
ruffle any feathers and of course are
not a violation of YouTube's algorithms
everyone's welcome here except oh I
don't know if we are but it's our
Channel
not sure how that works